ils attendent que vous votiez pour eux à
la maison je sais ce que vous dites
camille comment on fait pour voter bah
oui on fait comment pour voter
excellente question de la villa via cinq
inédit donc uniquement disponible sur ce
cd tout à fait cinq livres issus de lyme
à delhi 5 life bardin mais j'écris aussi
bon non mais c'est pas grave mais il
fait ce que je sais c'est normal dès
l'es2 les lives avec des lives non faut
que bungie en belgique id non non non
mais
life own site un classique de la
littérature française
vas-y non mais non mais pas de vous
tourner et pas vers lui
[Rires]
non merci non attendez l'étranger il n'y
avait que c'était tout à l'air de clio
qui
s'est pas du coup dit
j'aimerais juste qu'on regarde une photo
elle est un peu culte cette photo pour
tout vous dire elle est dans mon bureau
depuis quelques années oui non mais elle
est assez intéressant banda de 2005
c'est vous et lui cela date de l'époque
où effectivement vous étiez en campagne
pour le référendum et il ya ce sourire
qui apparaît entre vous et lui quand
vous voyez cette photo qu'on ne voit pas
mais que j'aimerais qu'on voit qui va
peut-être arriver si elle arrive et
n'arrive peut-être pas à l'appeler dé
censuré
et plus ne servait plus le service
public on en sait laisser la république
parce que tout le monde
est ce que c'est bien vous oui oui je
faisais c'était une photo je peux mais
on agit là développe c'est une photo qui
n'est pas fait par rapport au référendum
même si c'est quand même s'il est à
cette période c'était les deux chefs de
parti qui dialoguait je pense pour un
hebdomadaire n'ira pas lequel et nous
étions les deux éléments majeurs de la
vie politique à ce moment là les
perturbateurs de la vie politique
il m'est arrivé de gagner des paris
grâce à c dans l'air en plaçant dans
l'émission des mots que m'avait proposé
des amis ainsi pour faire plaisir à ma
fille j'ai placé un jour le mot
libellules une autre fois succédané une
autre fois plus difficile ornithorynque
merci c dans l'air regardez tous les
copains de la saison sont revenus et à
la wave y avoue sa sont tous habillés en
doré on dirait des ferrero rocher se
trompe ou parmi les factures laissées
par son prédécesseur il y en a une qui
l'a particulièrement choqué celle pour
la déco du bureau du maire à un canapé à
4500 euros
deux fauteuils à 1900 euros pièce cette
table basse ni l'euro au total dix mille
euros pour ce salon si l'on compte la
petite touche lumineuse
devait on quitte lumière bleue
extrêmement utiles aux défis mois cette
baisse est surtout que représentent ces
boutons 1 jamais vraiment regardé en
fait c'est la royauté
non parce que j'ai des armoiries qui
sont pas forcément royal ça peut être
républicain je sais pas moi enfin bon si
républicains ouais je ne sais pas non
mais c'est marie républicaine donc cas
voilà démocratique important et ça la
démocratie
rcd très belle ses très belles chaises
qui sont vagues étaient destinés à l'est
dans la salle leur salle des mariages
donc évidemment c'est déjà si vous
voulez toucher le csss et très doux je
crois que l'assise est très agréable
comptez 600 euros l'unité
et il y en a cinquante huit comme ça
voilà vous avez 600 euros 600 euros 600
euros 600 euros 600 euros s'ils sont
heureux en tout il y en a pour près de
35000 euros de chaises mais c'est que
les invités soient à l'aise je demandais
à julien courbet est ce qu'il y en a 6
es ce que vous avez pris vos besoins
enfin fait attention
quand vous avez pris vos
on sent une envie d'un élan de politesse
générosité dans cette phrase alors ça
tombe totalement accrue et d'ailleurs on
m'a vite donne une recette que je fais
tous les matins et c'est génial parce
que je n'ai plus du tout de fringale ou
de baisse d'énergie moi je vous dis joue
le contient c'est trop banane dans un
blender avec 4 pruneaux de grosses
cuillères d'huile de coco bio on se dit
mais c'est hyper riches surtout hyper
enfin saft est hâtif
non non non je plaisante la banane et le
pruneau
[Musique]
carton plein
vigreux tout
ampli ma vie d'un mieux que je ne
saurais dire
c'est beaucoup
alors un conseil à donner à tout le
monde quand ça sort pas aider à ce que
ça sorte c'est pour le transit c'est ça
le désordre là dedans
ça doit être le stress des exams t'as vu
comment manche
je sais c'est une solution commence par
faire caca furent kaka aide à évacuer
les intestins on pousse vers le bas tout
est en ordre tu as raison je me sens
mieux et c'est surtout très agréable
changer
sinon
félicienne non c'est pas rigolo si parce
que parce que j'étais folle a changé
j'ai compris c'est pas sûr bouffon ou
blaireau il commence aussi par b
baltringue très bien il était venu à
l'inter michalik à un mois j'avais dit
que je n'aimais pas les comédies
musicales il m'a dit non mais c'est vrai
j'aime pas ça m'avait dit chiche venez
venez voir les producteurs et vous
m'avez retourner se trompent chaque
stefan tests d'attention ce que vous
dites heures à la salle a mis
d'accord et garçons
vous m'aviez retourner bon
toujours
vous rendez compte de ce que ça provoque
lorsque vous chantez je vais t'aimer
comme on ne t'a jamais aimé ça mais plus
loin que tes rêves l'on imaginé je
mettais mes affaires
c'est ce que vous recherchez mais oui ça
fait partie du spectacle le 9 de nicolas
les masculins oui oui éjaculer au
féminin donc bon et j'ai glissé l'autre
effectivement c'est un verbe transitif
aussi aussi rarement mais transitive
c'est curieux comme on est dans la même
catégorie comme ça sur le même nombre de
lettres c'est bizarre étonnant avec des
interrogations plus même dans les deux
cas
oui oui c'est fort boyard nous offre des
images inoubliables des invités qu'on
soit vous avez fait vous seront jamais
alors je le survêtement me va très mal
moi pareil je dis toujours j'ai toujours
peur d'une érection
mais c'est vrai ça quoi rêver il ya
toujours des le pire c'est que ça se
voit pas
[Applaudissements]
riche en niveau
les amis il n'y a qu'une seule chose qui
au dessus de vous c'est vous même je
vous le jure
n'arrêtez jamais d'essayer croyait en
dieu il est puissant et ça
c'est un petit pas pour l'homme un grand
pas pour la première
ça vous a plu non merci